Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu einem neuen
Video!
Heute möchte ich meine fünf absolut liebsten
Tomatensorten überhaupt mit euch teilen!
Es gibt ja so, so, so viele Tomatensorten
da draußen und das ist oft super schwierig,
da eine Auswahl zu treffen, deswegen finde
ich solche Videos super inspirierend!
Ich werde euch heute fünf Sorten vorstellen,
die wir immer, immer, immer wieder anbauen,
weil sie sich so bewährt haben und weil sie
so, so lecker sind.
Ich habe noch ganz, ganz viele andere Gartentipps
für euch parat, also abonniert den Kanal
und drückt auch die Glocke, damit ihr benachrichtigt
werdet, sobald das nächste Video erscheint
und jetzt wünsche ich euch viel Spaß mit
den Tomatensorten.
Alle Sorten, die ich hier vorstelle, sind
übrigens samenfest, das heißt, dass ihr
immer wieder, jedes Jahr, Saatgut von euren
eigenen Tomaten behalten könnt und dass im
nächsten Jahr anbauen könnt.
Und da gar nicht mehr davon abhängig seid,
dass ihr jedes Jahr neues Saatgut kaufen müsst.
Falls ihr euch fragt, woran man erkennt, ob
Saatgut samenfest ist, das steht entweder
auf den Tütchen mit drauf, es gibt auch Züchter,
die nur sagen samenfestes Saatgut vermehren.
Ihr könnt das auch über das Ausschlussverfahren
feststellen, wenn auf dem Saatgut Tütchen
hinter dem Namen der Sorte ein F1 steht, dann
ist das Hybrid-Saatgut, das man nicht ohne
weiteres im eigenen Garten vermehren kann.
Vielleicht habt ihr ja eben schon gespickelt...
auf Platz Nummer 5 haben wir diese Tomatensorte,
die heißt "Celsior".
Ich hoffe ich spreche das richtig aus.
Das ist eine Sorte, die ich aus einem ganz
bestimmten Grund anbaue und zwar, weil sie
in der zweiten Hälfte der Saison, also gegen
August bis Oktober nochmal richtig Gas gibt
und dann erst richtig Ertrag abwirft, wenn
die anderen Sorten schon anfangen zu schwächeln,
gerade Freiland-Tomaten werden ja superschnell
von Braunfäule befallen und werfen dann um
die Jahreszeit oft gar nicht mehr so den Ertrag
ab.
Und dann kommt "Celsior" ins Spiel und legt
richtig los, deswegen baue ich diese Sorte
super gerne an.
Es ist eine Cocktailtomate, eine rote.
Ich habe leider dieses Jahr, glaube ich, keine
Bilder oder kaum Bilder von diesen Sorten,
die ich euch hier vorstelle, gemacht, also
muss ich es euch erklären und ja, ich kann
ja jetzt auch nicht rausgehen und da Tomaten
ernten, die ich euch zeigen kann, weil wir
gerade erst Januar haben.
Aber Celsior macht ungefähr so große, rote
Früchte sicherlich die leckerste Sorte im
Gemüsegarten, aber durchaus sehr lecker und
eben, weil er so spät im Jahr noch mal richtig
Gas gibt, ist das eine Sorte, die das ganze
andere Tomaten-Sortiment gut gut ergänzt.
Platz Nummer 4 belegt tatsächlich eine gelbe
Tomatensorte!
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das auch so geht,
aber ich finde gelbe Tomaten oft super, super
langweilig, weil die einfach nicht den Säuregehalt
haben, den rote Tomatensorten haben, deswegen
bin ich da immer etwas zögerlich.
Aber diese Tomate, die ich euch jetzt hier
vorstelle, die hat absolut was auf dem Kasten,
obwohl sie gelb ist.
Das ist die "Ananastomate".
Ich hoffe es fokussiert, ja.
Die "Ananastomate" ist eine wunderschöne,
gelbe, riesige Tomatensorte, mit rötlichen
Streifen oder Marmorierung drauf, die super,
super, super lecker ist und sehr ertragreich,
also eine absolute Empfehlung von mir für
euch, die "Ananastomate".
Das Einzige was ich da empfehlen würde, ist,
dass man die geschützt anbaut, am besten
im Gewächshaus, weil sie sehr Wärme bedürftig
ist.
Generell sind alle Tomaten dankbar für ein
Dach über dem Kopf, aber einige sind eben
ein bisschen Freiland geeigneter als andere.
Und die "Ananastomate" gehört da eher nicht
dazu.
Bevor ich hier jetzt alle gelben Tomatensorten
schlechtrede, verratet mir doch, ob ihr eine
gelbe Sorte kennt, die auch so lecker ist
oder ob ihr auch eher enttäuscht seid von
gelben Sorten.
Ich freue mich immer, wenn ich mich eines
Besseren belehrt.
Ich fände es auf jeden Fall schön, noch
ein paar mehr gelbe Sorten anzubauen, also
hinterlasst mir einen Kommentar, wenn ihr
da eine Empfehlung für mich habt.
Platz 3 belegt eine Sorte, die durch das Haus-Tomaten
Projekt von Dreschflegel bekannt wurde.
Dreschflegel ist eine Züchter-Gemeinschaft
von Züchtern, die es sich zur Aufgabe gemacht
haben, samenfeste und alte Gemüsesorten zu
erhalten und zu züchten.
Ein ganz tolles Projekt und die haben eben
ihre Kunden dazu aufgerufen, Tomatensorten,
die sie selber in ihrem eigenen Garten immer
weiter vermehren, die es so im Handel gar
nicht gibt, bei Dreschflegel einzuschicken.
Und da ist eine Sorte zutage gekommen, die
nennt sich "sibirisches Birnchen" eine, ups,
so, jetzt könnt ihr es lesen, eine sehr,
sehr süße Tomatensorte.
Die sieht nämlich wirklich aus, wie so ein
kleines Birnchen, so ein kleines rotes Birnchen
macht die, sehr viele Früchte, super robust,
also die ist auch absolut Freiland geeignet
und sehr, sehr ertragreich.
Die Früchte schmecken sehr, sehr, sehr, lecker,
also das kann ich euch sehr ans Herz legen,
das "sibirische Birnchen" einmal in eurem
Garten auszuprobieren.
Verratet mir mal unten in den Kommentaren,
was eure allerliebsten Tomatensorten sind,
so können wir da unten in den Kommentaren
noch so ein zweites Tomaten-Ranking machen.
Ihr könnt dann den anderen auch immer einen
Daumen hoch oder Daumen runter geben, je nachdem
ob ihr einverstanden seid und so können wir
uns noch viel mehr inspirieren und gegenseitig
tolle Tipps für Tomatensorten geben!
Langsam wird es spannend oder, wer ist wohl
auf Platz Nummer 2?
Es ist eine Sorte, die ihr wahrscheinlich
alle kennt, eine sehr beliebte Sorte und das
absolut zu Recht.
Es ist die "Black Cherry" Cocktailtomate,
eine super leckere, rote Tomate, die so einen
lila Überzug hat.
Also die ist nicht schwarz, auch wenn sie
"Black Cherry" heißt, eine sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr leckere Tomate und das ist vor
allem mit Abstand die ertragreichste Sorte
gewesen in unserem Garten in den letzten drei
Jahren.
Wir haben die auch schon im Freiland sehr
erfolgreich angebaut, auch wenn die oft nicht
als Freiland geeignet gelistet wird, finde
ich sie doch wirklich sehr robust und supertoll,
also die Cocktailtomate "Black Cherry", eine
absolute Empfehlung von uns, wirklich, also
Platz 1 übertrifft die wirklich nur minimal
im Geschmack.
Es war ein ganz knappes Rennen hier!
Und "Trommelwirbel" Applaus für Platz Nr.
1!
Da landet eine Tomatensorte, die auch super
lecker ist, es ist mit Abstand die leckerste
Sorte, die wir je angebaut haben.
Es ist eine super ertragreiche Sorte, auch
eine Cocktailtomate.
Es ist die "Zuckertraube"!
Aber ich habe jetzt kein Saatgut-Tütchen
mehr, nur noch selber gesammeltes Saatgut.
Das ist eine super, super, super leckere Tomaten-Sorte,
die schmeckt genauso, wie sie sich anhört.
"Zuckertraube", die macht ungefähr so große
rote Früchte und zwar massenhaft, die wächst
auch im Freiland einigermaßen.
Ich würde sie schon eher geschützt anbauen
und die schmeckt mit Abstand am aller, aller
besten!
Deswegen ist sie auf Platz 1!
Meine ganze Familie ist so begeistert von
dieser Tomaten-Sorte, dass die mittlerweile
fast jeder, der einen Garten hat bei uns,
anbaut.
Also eine absolute Empfehlung die "Zuckertraube",
probiert die auf jeden Fall mal aus!
Ansonsten kannst du dir hier, falls du noch
kein Pflanzplan erstellt hast, meine Video-Reihe
anschauen, da gehen wir das Schritt-für-Schritt
zusammen durch.
Da unten ist auch noch ein spannendes Video!
Ich hoffe wir sehen uns gleich wieder!
Bis dann, Ciao!